RONALD SMITH: OK, so we are
starting this new subject,
which is a really important one.
And we'll be covering at least
these subtopics, starting with
the carbon cycle, then the
question of whether we can use
the Holocene as a reference
period for judging recent
climate change.
We'll go over the history and
the theory of the warming and
cooling we've had over the last
hundred years or so, talk
about the IPCC forecasts for the
future, and then go back,
in a way, and kind of summarize
some of this by
talking about this interesting
and useful concept of climate
sensitivity.
So it's quite a lot
of material.
The book is chapter 13.
A couple of you have commented
that in the earlier editions,
there may not even be
such a chapter.
So please check with your
classmates that have the
current edition and look at
their chapter 13 and see what
the deal is.
If you don't have that chapter,
you may want to
borrow someone else's textbook
for a few hours while you read
through that chapter.
But a lot of the material, as
I'll indicate in a minute, is
coming out of the
IPCC reports.
And those are--some are already
put online on the
class's server for you,
others you can
find very easily online.
Just Google IPCC.
It'll take you to their
big website.
There's lots of different
reports, you just have to
figure out which ones you're
looking for there.
So even if you don't have a
chapter 13, you can get a lot
of this from the IPCC reports.
Now I wanted to point out that
this subject we're dealing
with now, I think, is one of the
four great paradigm shifts
in the earth sciences.
The four, in my mind, being the
theory of evolution, that
is, Darwin's idea of
the mutability of
species back in the 1860s.
The theory of the Ice Ages,
which we've spoken about in
this course.
The idea that just 14,000 years
ago, we had a thick
layer of ice covering over much
of what is today open,
useful land.
The theory of plate tectonics,
which helps us to understand
the layout of the continents,
how that has changed through
geologic time.
The difference between
continental crust and ocean
crust. It even helps us to
understand the shape of the
ocean basins.
And then the theory of global
warming, which we'll be
dealing with now.
Now, these each have their own
characteristics, but on a
scientific front, they all
were true revolutions.
In other words, they changed the
very most basic ideas of
how we thought about the
different subjects of biology
and climate and geology, and
then, not only climate for
global warming, but also the
role of humans on the planet.
There are books, interesting
books, written on the history
of each of these.
Fascinating reading.
How they were resisted, how they
were promoted, what kinds
of evidence finally tipped it
over so that the majority of
the scientific community
finally accepted these.
Fascinating reading in the
history of human thought.
Of course, the theory of
evolution was resisted
strongly by the church at that
time because it changed the
way we thought about humans
and human nature.
Still resisted to this
day in some areas.
The theory of the Ice Ages and
plate tectonics I don't think
had any kind of resistance or
even that much notoriety in
the general public.
So they were mostly battles
fought within cadre of
scientists.
So that's a little different.
But then we get to the theory
of global warming, and now
we're back in a subject that
is of great interest to the
general public as well, and
comes straight into politics.
And it has a stake,
a current stake.
Now, all of these things were
interesting--those first three
were interesting intellectually,
but none of
them required that we do much
in response to whether the
theory was accepted or not.
Where the theory of global
warming is a little different
because it has to do with not
only the role of humans on the
planet and the question of
whether there are too many
people and our lifestyle is
wrong, but also in many
respects it brings in the issue
whether we should be
changing our lifestyle or
changing the way we do things.
So here we are.
And so you and I are living
through this one.
Not only is it a scientific
debate, but it has these
political and economic
consequences.
It's really a mess, because
it's all these fears of
discussion are engaged in the
theory of--in the discussions
of the theory of
global warming.
Any comments or questions
on this?
So, of course, I'm going to try
to approach this in the
most boring, scientific way that
I can and try to keep to
a large extent out of the
politics and these other
discussions.
But we can't avoid dealing
with some of these.
It used to be that, when you
went to someone's house or a
cocktail party, your companion
would whisper in your ear, now
remember, don't talk about
politics or religion.
And now you have to say, don't
talk about politics or
religion or global warming,
because you get into some
terrible battles quite
innocently, making the most
benign remarks.
And suddenly, everybody's
in an uproar.
So, particularly hard for
someone who works in this
field to avoid that kind of
awkward party situation.
So as I've indicated, for a lot
of the discussion, then,
that you'll do, and that I will
do, and that everybody
else does, your primary
reference material are these
very valuable IPCC reports.
There have been a series of
IPCC reports, and the most
recent one, called the
Fourth Assessment,
was finished in 2007.
And of course, the
Intergovernmental Panel on
Climate Change is busily working
on the next one.
I don't know when the target
date is, but probably within a
year or two, there
will be the Fifth
Assessment of climate change.
And some of that material
is already being leaked.
You can find it on
their website.
But for the most part, we're
going to be going back and
focusing most of our attention
on the 2007 report.
But there have been other things
more recent, such as an
interesting National Academy of
Sciences report on, what's
the word they used?
Sudden, they used a different
word sudden climate change,
they did a particular
study on how fast
climate change will occur.
And I've got that posted on
the lab course website.
A special report, also by the
National Academy, on high
latitude climate change, and
both of those are more recent
than 2007, so those will give
you some updated material.
And there is other for example,
if you go to this
website, RealClimate.com, which
has a reputation for
being a little bit on the
liberal side of the issue, but
nevertheless, a lot of
scientists post recent results
on RealClimate.com.
And if you're going to do that,
though, you should be
evenhanded and go to some of
these other anti websites,
like, what are they called,
ClimateSkeptic.com
and things like that.
So be sure you, if you're going
to bookmark some of
these things, try to get an even
number of bookmarks on
the two sides of the issue.
You'll have to decide for
yourself, in the end, which
material you accept and
which ones you reject.
I'll try to help with
that a little bit.
So let's start out by looking at
the carbon cycle, which is
really one of the core
issues in the debate.
It has to do with what controls
the carbon dioxide
level in the atmosphere.
We know the carbon dioxide is
a powerful greenhouse gas.
It has a linear molecular
structure, but it can flap and
it can vibrate in such
a way to absorb and
emit infrared radiation.
So it's a powerful
greenhouse gas.
It's in part controlled by
anthropogenic processes, so
it's at the center of
the whole debate.
You have to know this.
You have to know that when you
burn something like coal, the
chemical reaction looks like
that, carbon plus oxygen.
You oxidize the carbon to form
CO2, and that's a gas that
goes into the atmosphere.
This comes from the atmosphere,
and this would be
coming from some buried
deposit of coal.
If you're burning methane, which
is CH4, you combine that
with oxygen and you get two
by-products, water vapor and
carbon dioxide.
The water vapor we pretty much
neglect, because it goes into
the atmosphere as water vapor,
but then instantly, it becomes
part of the normal
hydrologic cycle.
And if you remember early in
the course, we computed the
average residence time
for water vapor.
Anybody remember
what that was?
Nine days, yeah, eight
days, nine days.
So in other words, it's cycled
back in rain to the earth's
surface or the ocean very, very
quickly, and so it really
plays no role in the
greenhouse effect.
Let me be careful.
Water vapor is also a very
powerful greenhouse gas.
And because there's so much of
it, it's actually in a sense
the strongest of all the
greenhouse gases.
But it is controlled by
the natural system.
It doesn't matter how
much we add into it.
The level is not going to
change for that reason.
It's going to be controlled
by the own, the internal
processes within
the atmosphere.
Nothing we can do in adding
water vapor is going to have
any influence on changing the
amount of water vapor in the
atmosphere.
So it's important to know that
water vapor is one product,
but in terms of what that does
to climate, that particular
piece is negligible
in the sense
that I have just described.
Propane is another
form of gas.
It can be burned for heat,
and the reaction--
the stoichiometry is a
little bit different.
I've tried to balance
those reactions.
I'm not a chemist, so you
may want to check me.
Add up the carbons, add up the
oxygen, be sure everything
adds up properly, and correct
if I've gone wrong here.
But basically water
and CO2 again, and
the same thing implies.
The CO2 stays in the
atmosphere, influencing climate.
The water vapor quickly gets
cycled into the natural
hydrologic system.
Another thing that's going on,
we've talked about calcium
carbonate in this course a
couple of times because that
excess calcium that we found in
the Quinnipiac River that
wasn't there in ocean water,
we argued goes into making
calcium carbonate in
the oceans, shells,
limestones, and so on.
There's a lot of that around in
the earth's climate system.
If we take a little bit of
that and heat it, we can
separate it into the material
that's used to make cement,
but that releases CO2 as well.
So there's another
source of CO2.
It's not quite as powerful
as these.
I'm going to show you some
numbers in a minute.
But that is another significant
input of CO2, is
the making of cement from
natural calcium carbonate that
was precipitated in the oceans
by either living
or non-living processes.
Stop me if you have any
questions on this.
So when you burn fossil fuels
then, you're putting carbon
dioxide in the atmosphere.
And that comes from carbon
that's been stored in the
earth, typically for 60
or 100 million years.
Remember in the Cretaceous
Period, way back when the
dinosaurs were alive, that's
when a lot of forests were
being the earth was very warm
during that period of time.
You had tropical forests almost
everywhere on the
continents.
Those trees would
eventually fall.
And the productivity was so
high, instead of their rotting
and putting that CO2 back in the
atmosphere, they would be
covered over by another and
then another and another.
So you ended up sequestering all
of that carbon down in the
crust of the earth where it's
been sitting there for 60 or
100 million years.
And now we're suddenly pulling
it back out and burning it and
putting it back into
the atmosphere.
And in the oceans, too,
you had algae growing,
phytoplankton, that would sink
to the bottom of the ocean,
and instead of rotting and
returning to the ocean system,
they would get covered over.
And today you have all of these
oil deposits beneath the
ocean bottom.
And then we dig those up
and we burn those, too.
So both on the land and in the
oceans, we are removing
ancient, very ancient fossil
carbon and burning it to put
it back in the atmosphere.
Now the natural, the
modern biosphere is
active in this as well.
For example, trees remove a lot
of carbon dioxide during
the summer season when they're
growing and use that to build
their woody biomass.
Remember, the trunk of
a tree is about 1/5
or one quarter carbon.
Well, where did that
carbon come from?
It didn't come from the soil.
From the soil, the tree is
getting water and it's getting
nutrients, like nitrogens and
phosphorus, but almost all of
the carbon to build a tree
trunk is coming from the
atmosphere.
I mentioned in another context
that I did a project down on a
small island in the Caribbean
last spring.
And we were flying an aircraft
around the island.
One of the sensors we had on
the airplane was a carbon
dioxide sensor so we could
measure how much carbon
dioxide was in the atmosphere
upstream of the island, over
the island, and downstream
of the island.
The island was forested.
It's the island of Dominica,
one of the few Caribbean
islands that still has its
original forest. And when we
flew downstream of the island,
across the wake of the island,
we found a slight deficit
in carbon dioxide.
In other words, the air that
had come from upstream and
passed over the island's forests
had lost a little bit
of carbon dioxide to those
trees, and we found that
deficit downwind.
Now, this has been well known.
You can measure this in
lots of other ways.
But this is yet another way to
convince yourself that the
forests are actively removing
carbon dioxide from the
atmosphere all the time
that they're growing.
But then, they recycle
some of that.
For example, the material in
leaves that falls to earth at
this time of year then rots and
respires over the winter
season to put that little
bit of carbon back in.
Now it still has its woody
biomass, which is most of it,
but a little bit goes back into
the atmosphere, which
gives that little bit of wiggle
in the Keeling curve
that you were studying in
your Time Series Lab.
So I want to emphasize that the
biosphere is a very active
player in this carbon cycle.
Certainly on the long term, but
then on the modern time
scales as well.
Any questions there?
Yeah.
STUDENT: Does the carbon that's
sequestered in the
wood, when, like, the wood from
the tree rots, is that
also, is that rereleased
in the atmosphere?
PROFESSOR:
That's right.
So if a tree, if a modern tree
today does fall and then you
watch it over some years, it
rots and kind of disappears
into the Earth.
That carbon ends up back
in the atmosphere.
A little bit may be left in the
soil as organic carbon,
but then over a longer period
of time, maybe ten or twenty
years, that too will go back
to the atmosphere.
So there are few places on
earth, however, where you're
getting this sequestration,
where you're getting things
falling on top of it faster
than it can rot.
But I would say, for example,
in most of these New England
forests, most of the ancient
tree material is going back
into the atmosphere.
Well, in fact, that's one of the
problems with this idea of
solving the global warming
problem by
planting lots of trees.
Because what that will do in the
short run, indeed, it will
draw extra CO2 from the
atmosphere and store it in the
biomass of the tree.
But a typical tree of the
species you're familiar with,
both conifers and deciduous,
typically have lifetimes of 60
to 80 to 100 years.
And then they will fall and
they'll rot and the material
will go back.
So it is a temporary fix,
perhaps, to reducing carbon
dioxide buildup in the
atmosphere, but by no means is
it permanent because of the
short turnover time of trees
in the forest.
So this diagram will summarize
some of this.
And there are two types
of numbers on here.
There are, for example,
storage.
These numbers are in boxes.
And those units would be
in gigatons of carbon.
And then the arrows, which are
the fluxes, going between
these reservoirs, and
those units are in
gigatons per year of carbon.
So for example, in the
atmosphere typically and this
is a calculation you could
do but we have about
760 gigatons of carbon.
Remember, that's the
C in the CO2.
If you want to know what the
mass of the carbon dioxide is,
be sure to include the mass of
the two oxygens that are on
the carbon dioxide.
This is just the carbon
in the carbon dioxide.
For example, let's look at how
it interacts with terrestrial
production, the one I've just
been talking about, of trees
and other biomass on
the continents.
So about 60 gigatons per year
is put in and about 62 is
taken out every year.
So it's a very dynamic
reservoir.
The difference, however,
is rather small.
There's an excess going from
the atmosphere into the
biosphere of about two or
three gigatons per year.
It's this big exchange, the 60
and the 60 that's responsible
for that wiggle in the
Keeling curve.
And it's the annual difference,
that two or three
units, that's responsible
for that trend
in the Keeling curve.
I'll show you that Keeling
curve in a moment.
You've seen it before,
but that's a
central part of our argument.
The oceans are somewhat similar,
so there's biological
activity taking place
in the oceans.
We've talked about that.
We've seen that it's confined to
certain parts of the ocean
where you can get nutrients
coming up into
the euphotic zone.
The numbers are even bigger
than for the terrestrial
biomass, but they too have
a similar characteristic.
Large instantaneous cycling,
but over a year, only about
two gigatons, and going in the
same direction, going from the
atmosphere into the ocean.
There's the cement production,
about 6.5.
And there's some other
things here.
This is one to look at.
The amount of fossil fuel
reserves still in the crust of
the earth is 4,000 units
of gigatons.
So you can imagine if you burn
the rest of that, what that
would do to that number.
It would be 4,760, unless, you
probably should take into
account this removal as well.
But it would be a huge number if
one were to burn all of the
fossil fuel reserves and put
that carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere.
Questions on this busy
diagram here?
I'm going to use these numbers
to do something we did early
in the course.
I want to compute residence
times, because sometimes
that's helpful to get a physical
feeling for the way
these reservoirs work.
So I'm going to be using the
atmosphere as the reservoir,
and then either these
large monthly--
month by month fluxes or the
smaller annual total fluxes to
compute the residence time.
So residence time is for CO2.
On the month by month, on the
seasonal basis, I'll take that
760 gigatons and divide it
here I'm just using the
atmospheric number.
I probably should have summed
up the atmosphere and the
ocean number, but I'm just using
the atmospheric number.
And when I do that, I get a
pretty short time, 13 years.
I get even a shorter time if
I use, if I put the ocean
numbers in there as well.
So there's this rapid cycling
that's taking place.
But in a way it's kind of
irrelevant because it cancels
itself out at the
end of the year.
So I'm not going to put
a great deal of
stock in this number.
It is a residence time.
It is computed in the proper
way, but the fluxes we're
using are balanced over
the course of a year.
And so, the numbers is
not of great use.
On the longer term, I'll take
760 and divide it by one of
those imbalances.
Now again, I've used the
imbalance for just the
terrestrial biomass.
Maybe I could have changed that
to four by adding up two
here and two there.
But you can see what
that will do to the
numbers pretty easily.
I've just used two gigatons
per year here.
And I got 380 years.
Now this is a more useful
number because this is
actually how long a carbon
dioxide molecule is likely to
stay in the atmosphere before
it's returned into one of the
biosphere sinks.
So when we're trying to predict
the future of carbon
dioxide concentrations in the
atmosphere, we have to realize
that it stays there for quite a
long period of time in spite
of these fluxes back and
forth between the
atmosphere and the biosphere.
Questions there?
So from economic data, we can
get a pretty good handle on
the carbon dioxide emissions
that have taken
place in past years.
And here you see
various curves.
The black is the total,
where all the others
have been summed up.
The two largest independent
sources have been coal, in the
green, and petroleum,
in the dark blue.
Each of those is about six
billion metric tons
of carbon per year.
So this is not accumulated.
This is what's emitted
each year.
And of course, that number has
been growing since the
beginning of the Industrial
Revolution, where we began to
use fossil fuels for steam
engines and then for
electricity generation and
transportation and so on.
Natural gas is growing
rapidly now.
Cement production is lower
but still growing.
And a small amount is the gas
flaring that you see in some
of these oils fields and gas
fields, just burning off
excess gas.
So it's rising very rapidly.
No sign at all of any
decrease in this.
There have been some temporary
for example, in the 1970s
there was a kind of an oil
crisis, and you see a tiny
little bit of a dip there.
But generally it's just
a curve that's
rising very, very steeply.
And this is the rate at which
we are putting CO2 into the
atmosphere.
This is not the accumulated
amount.
Questions there?
So we've been monitoring carbon
dioxide concentration.
The first measurement started on
the Mauna Loa Observatory,
up on the Big Island of Hawaii,
up on top of the high
volcanic peak there.
There's a picture of
the laboratory.
And I know you've seen this
before, and now I know that
you're familiar with it because
you're working with it
in your lab.
This is exactly the same data
set that I gave you to work on
in Lab Number Four.
And the features here, of
course, plotting the units are
in parts per million by
volume, not by mass.
So it's by molecule.
It's a ratio, for every for
every million molecules of
air, there are 320--
molecules of carbon dioxide.
That's the way you would
read that number.
There's an annual oscillation
that has to do with the mostly
the Northern Hemisphere biomass
drawing carbon dioxide
in the summer and releasing
it in the winter.
And then on top of that, you've
got a trend, which you
can see from the smoothed
line here.
And that slope has
been increasing.
And of course, the increase in
that slope is because of this,
the rate at which we've been
putting CO2 into the
atmosphere has been
increasing.
So that rate of change of carbon
dioxide concentration
has been increasing as well.
So any questions on the it's
called the Keeling curve
because the scientist that got
this started back in the '50s
was Charles Keeling.
He passed away a couple of years
ago, but he's one of the
great heroes in climate
science.
To have the forethought to get
an accurate measurement of
this type going early enough,
so by the time we got to the
year 2000, we had a good record
and the beginning of a
clear understanding of what's
causing this rise.
Now here's another diagram from
the IPCC report that's a
really important one.
You can read through the legend,
but I put these little
labels up here as well.
This is the annual change in
carbon dioxide concentration
in parts per million
by volume.
And the bars are the actual
annual change.
And if that curve looks
familiar, if those bar graph
looks familiar, it's because
you computed that very same
quantity in your lab exercise.
So you're familiar with
how to do this.
And the increase started out at
about 0.5 parts per million
change per year and is now about
three times that amount
of increase per year.
Up above is the expected change
from emissions if all
the CO2 we're putting in, namely
that, remained in the
atmosphere, and it's about
twice what we're actually
finding as the increase every
year in the atmosphere.
So here's what we've
learned from this.
The biomass is taking in about
half of that extra that we are
emitting into the atmosphere.
That's rather remarkable.
The reason seems to be that
carbon dioxide is in many
places around the earth and the
ocean a limiting quantity
for photosynthesis.
So that when you increase the
concentration of CO2, you
increase the rate at
which plants grow.
It's called CO2 fertilization.
So as CO2 has increased, the
plants have tried to take some
of that excess back out.
They take about half
of it out.
There's some speculation about
whether they will continue to
be able to take out half,
because they need other
nutrients as well.
They need phosphorus and
nitrogen, they need water, if
they're plants growing
on land.
And it might be that as these
other ingredients become
limiting, the biosphere will no
longer be able to do this
for us, and these numbers
could creep up.
As this one increases, these
might actually creep up
eventually to become more equal
to the amount that we're
putting in every year.
Questions on that?
So it's interesting to look
at this from a historical
perspective because what
we're doing now is so
unusual and so rapid.
So if we go back 10,000
years, this
roughly covers the Holocene.
Here is carbon dioxide
concentration in parts per
million by volume.
And of course, the Keeling curve
is the little red part
here, it's just that
little part.
Before that time, we get that
data from the ice cores, the
little vesicles, the little
bubbles in the ice cores give
us the data prior
to that time.
But it was pretty flat through
the Holocene, with a value of
about 270 or 280 or 290
parts per million.
And then in the Industrial
Revolution, on this time
scale, it shoots up
almost vertically.
If you blow that up, blow that
time scale up, and show it
here going back to 1800, it was
slow at first and then has
become more and more rapid, as
we discussed in the previous
couple of diagrams because the
rate of carbon dioxide
emissions has increased
so strongly.
We can go back even further
in geologic time.
And you've seen this kind
of thing before.
This is an ice core showing
carbon dioxide concentrations.
Here we are in the Holocene,
right about here, with
preindustrial levels
around 270 or 280.
But just prior to that, 15,000,
20,000 years ago at
the end of last Ice Age, the
values were down about 200
hundred, and then oscillated
around those lower levels for
at least 400,000 years.
It's hard to put this recent
data even on the same scale
because it plots as almost
a vertical line.
So the rate at which we're
putting CO2 in and changing
atmospheric composition is far
higher than anything one could
diagnose from previous
geologic eras.
There's another piece to this
argument that I find kind of
interesting.
It has to do with the
isotopes of carbon.
Carbon, like hydrogen and oxygen
that we spoke about
earlier in the week, come as
a primary element and then
various heavier isotopes.
And most carbon is Carbon
12, but there's a
Carbon 13 as well.
It's a stable isotope
of carbon.
And the buried fossil fuel
happens to be depleted in
Carbon 13 relative to the
normal Carbon 12.
So when we dig up this fossil
fuel and burn it, we're now
putting a lot of the dominantly
we're putting in
the Carbon 12 into the
atmosphere, which takes
whatever fraction we started
with, Carbon 13 to Carbon 12
in the atmosphere, and making
the overall carbon in the
atmosphere lighter, because
we're mixing in more of the
light carbon from the
fossil fuel burning.
And indeed, if you plot Delta
Carbon 13, using the same kind
of Delta notation we used
before, from 1977 to 2002,
it's a decreasing number.
This is data from
the South Pole.
Here's some data
from Mauna Loa.
And it shows also a
decreasing trend.
So some would argue, how do we
know that new carbon dioxide
in the atmosphere is
coming from the
burning of fossil fuels?
Well, one argument would have
been, well we're putting twice
that much in the atmosphere.
It makes sense that
at least half of
that would stick around.
It's a pretty powerful
argument.
But maybe this is even a more
powerful argument, because
that carbon we're
putting it has a
certain isotopic signature.
And now we see that signature
showing up in
the atmospheric carbon.
So it's another argument for the
case that the burning of
fossil fuels is what's leading
to that increase in carbon
dioxide in the atmosphere.
Questions on that.
Yes?
STUDENT: Do we know
why it's depleted
in the heavier isotope?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it
has to do with the plants that
originally took in
that carbon.
So when a plant grows, as I
mentioned, it takes carbon in
from the atmosphere to
build its biomass.
It actually prefers
the light isotope
over the heavy isotope.
So when those plants, way back,
100 million years ago,
were growing their biomass,
they were doing it
preferentially out
of Carbon 12.
And then when they got buried,
that left behind a lot of the
Carbon 13 in the atmosphere.
They buried a lot of
the Carbon 12.
Now we're reversing that,
putting the Carbon 12 back in
the atmosphere.
So it has to do it how plants
draw in CO2 into their leaves
and then use that to build
their biomass.
Good question.
So let's conclude, then,
our brief discussion
of the carbon cycle.
Fossil fuel burning is quickly
returning to the atmosphere
carbon stored for millions of
years in crustal reservoirs.
About half of the emitted CO2
stays in the atmosphere, and
we estimate it'll stay there
for at least a few hundred
years, given the cycling rate
between the biosphere and the
atmosphere.
The CO2 emission rate has
increased with time since the
beginning of the Industrial
Revolution.
And the current CO2
concentration, which is
approximately 395 parts per
million by volume, is the
highest in several
million years.
Let me be careful of
what I say here.
If I go back to this diagram,
which shows the last 400,000
years, clearly, now that we're
up at 390 or 395, that's way
higher than anything we've
had during the Ice Ages.
Yet if you go back way earlier,
say 50, 60, 100
million years ago, you'll find
periods in the earth's history
where the carbon dioxide
concentration in the
atmosphere was actually much
higher than it is even today.
So I don't want to make a
blanket statement saying that
it's as high as it's
ever been.
So instead I have said, it is
the highest it's been in
several million years.
But again, this is the kind of
an argument that arises.
Someone will say, well, yes,
we're putting a lot of CO2 in
the atmosphere, but it hasn't
by any means reached an
unprecedented level.
There have been periods in the
ancient earth history where
carbon dioxide concentrations
have been
much higher than this.
So it all depends on what you
want to use for your reference
timeframe as to what kind
of a statement you
make in this regard.
So be very careful about that
not to overstate the
uniqueness of the current carbon
dioxide concentration.
It's probably safe to say
there's never been a time in
Earth's history where the CO2 is
increasing as rapidly as it
is today, where the rate
has been as large.
But in terms of the absolute
amount, the record we're
setting now is only the record
for the last few million
years, not for--certainly not
for all of Earth's history.
So we've got a couple minutes
to begin the next section,
which is the Holocene as a
reference time period.
And I wanted you to be aware
of these particular often
discussed dates.
The retreat of the last large
ice sheets was occurring
around 11,000 years
before present.
That's right when the
ice was in the
process of melting back.
There was a warm period that
followed that called the
Holocene Optimum about seven to
eight thousand years ago.
That comes into the argument
when one is trying to find out
whether the current
warm climate is
unique even in the Holocene.
In other words, is our current
climate cooler or warmer than
this so-called Holocene
Optimum.
Much more recently, the Medieval
Warm Period, which
was roughly 1000 A.D.,
is another
important reference point.
This, by the way, is the
period when the Vikings
colonized Greenland.
There was a warm period when
they could grow crops in the
coastal regions of Greenland.
Then came the Little Ice Age
from 1400 to 1800 A.D. I'll
say a bit more about that.
And then we get into this
period, as you're seeing in
your data analysis in the lab,
of a more rapid climate change
over the last hundred
years or so.
So at the very minimum,
be aware of these.
And I'll point these out to
you as we look at various
historical reconstructions
of temperature.
For example, this one goes back
12,000 years, so that's
covering most of the Holocene.
And there's lots of different
data sets represented.
The black curve is an average
from a number of different
proxy data sets.
A proxy data set is where you
haven't measured temperature
directly with a thermometer,
but you're keeping track of
something that you think
depends on temperature.
Maybe it's lake levels.
Maybe it's isotopes.
Maybe it's there's a lot of
different things you can use.
They're all called climate
proxies, and they show a lot
of variability when you average
them together they
show some trend.
You see a rapid warming coming
out of the last Ice Age.
Then you see this climatic
optimum, what I called the
Holocene Optimum, right here.
And then it cooled
off a little bit.
And then there's some wiggles
near the end that we'll talk
about in just a minute.
And again these are plotted
as temperature anomalies.
They've chosen some period of
time as a reference to compute
the temperature anomaly.
This shows the last thousand
years or so.
So we're looking at a more
recent period of time.
And this is from the IPCC
report, I think.
Now I've forgotten
which is which.
Anyways, these are two different
authors' graphs
describing the Northern
Hemisphere temperature
reconstructions for the
last thousand years.
And they look a lot alike, but
I wanted to point out some
differences, because it's on
these differences that many
arguments will be built.
For example, this author
has shown a lot of
the different proxies.
And if you average those
together, you'd probably get
something that rose a little
bit in this period of time,
then sank a little bit more.
Here's the Little Ice Age, a
little cooler in this period
of time, and then you get the
rapid rise and rise again.
This author has suppressed all
the different proxies and
instead just shown the standard
deviation in the data.
I think it's like the two
sigma and the one sigma.
And while he does show a little
bit of a rise, the way
he's plotted it gives you the
idea that this is more of a
straight line, maybe slightly
decreasing, and then rising
rapidly at the end.
By the way, this is the famous
hockey stick diagram.
Because that shape looks a
bit like a hockey stick.
It used to be, twenty years ago,
when you Google hockey
stick, all you would get would
be websites about hockey.
Now when you Google hockey
stick, you get hockey and you
get climate change because of
all the controversy over this.
The author this original
diagram, Mike Mann, was a PhD
from our department.
In fact, I sat on
his committee.
This wasn't in his thesis,
it was in following work.
But I've tried to follow
the arguments.
The poor guy has been badgered
by the right wing anti-global
warming crowd incessantly.
Because the implication of this
diagram is that what's
happened in the past hundred
years is unique in regards to
what's happened over the
last thousand years.
But it seems to me you'd get
that impression from this
curve as well, even though
they've given you more of a
warming period in here, in
Medieval Warm Period.
Still, what's happening today
in steepness and in height
seems to be unique.
So all the arguments and the
dispute over the details of
how this diagram were
constructed seem to be kind of
moot now because we see
such a rapid rise the
last 20 or 30 years.
So, we're out of time
today, but we'll be
continuing this on Monday.